astrid roda bonjour bonjour christine
cupic tard via les ponts jour ou aux
auditrices et aux auditeurs vous êtes
donc candidate aux élections
législatives où vous présenter sur la
circonscription du nord sur la liste de
l'union des démocrates et indépendants
c'est exact alors pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin eh bien je
me présente en tant que candidate de la
circonscription nord alors pourquoi le
nord bat simplement parce que je suis né
à schoelcher j'habite la commune de
schoelcher donc c'est d'abord un choix
du coeur et puis le nord c'est quand
même 17 communes ce qui représente un
petit peu moins de la superficie de la
martinique et c'est donc une partie du
territoire qui méritent de rayonner
davantage alors je suis convaincu que
les actions qui convergent en tout cas
vers des intérêts communs ont pour
avantage de favoriser l'équilibré de
favoriser le développement économique et
social et c'est précisément sur ce point
que je me positionne en tant que
candidate à la députation
les actions qui doivent être menées il
faut qu'elles fonctionnent de manière
convergente de manière croisée mais
aussi de manière transversale c'est
nécessaire et vous savez que des projets
nous en avons nous avons aussi un des
idées et sans clivage de nos partis
politiques on se rend compte que tout le
monde est force de proposition nous
avons six outils travail et sage incite
cependant je pense que nous avons un
réel problème de méthodologie et c'est
encore précisément sur cet aspect que je
souhaite être force de proposition
auprès de l'assemblée et
particulièrement pour le nord caraïbe
enfin le nord la circonscription nord
que je représente alors on va aller un
petit peu plus dans le détail concernant
d'abord globalement le territoire
martinique quels sont les dossiers
citant ce site et en deux ou trois qui
pour vous sont prioritaires et que vous
souhaitez défendre si vous êtes élu à
l'assemblée nationale alors je vous
répondrais ceci christine cupide c'est
que je considère qu' il n'y a pas de
projet efficace sans liant nage je ne
conçois pas l'avancer deux sujets qui ne
soit pas en adéquation en transversalité
ou en synergie avec un autre c'est la
raison pour laquelle mes propositions
vont viser directement effectivement les
communes du nord mais toutes les autres
communes et toutes les autres
circonscriptions en profiteront y
compris l'outre-mer voilà et
concrètement alors les dossiers
prioritaires par exemple le nord d'après
vous quelles sont les problématiques
qu'il vaut qu'il faut en urgence
résoudre alors nous les problématiques
s'inscrivent dans une démarche globale
j'ai deux projets sur lesquels j'ai déjà
beaucoup travaillé parce que je suis sur
le terrain en ma qualité d'entrepreneur
je suis sur le terrain déjà depuis un
moment
je pense qu'il nous faut développer des
projets qu'ils soient structurées alors
je souhaite être force de proposition
pour la mise en place d'un fonds pour
projet structuré à condition que les
actions menées dans le cadre de ces
projets là bas fonctionne de manière
transversale sur la base de quatre
leviers minimum ses leviers sont pour
moi la restauration des centres bourgs
la valorisation de l'as de l'offre de
santé la valorisation de notre économie
sociale de notre économie locale pardon
et le lien social et je prends souvent
comme exemple la maison de santé que
tout le monde souhaite voir fleurir dans
nos bourgs et bien la maison de santé
est un projet structuré qui rentre
pleinement dans mes propositions parce
qu'il viendra lever l'ensemble des
leviers dont dont je viens de parler
alors vous qui êtes architecte je
suppose que l'aménagement du territoire
et notamment l'enclavement la
problématique de l'enclavement du nord
c'est une question qui vous parle
absolument j'y suis particulièrement
sensible et on parle de l'enclavement
sur ce sujet c'est bien je me rends
compte qu'il ya des choses qui ont qui
ont avancé mais j'aurais souhaité que
même dans le désenclavement qui est
guéri alik été réalisés récemment aux
lorrains bien que autour de ce projet de
désenclavement qu'il y ait des actions
qui fonctionne de manière transversale
pour impulser d'autres choses ce que je
regrette et je le dis très sincèrement
c'est que nos élus ont tendance à
fonctionner de manière individuelle sur
nos problématiques et je suis convaincu
j'insiste en disant
que la solution serait de faire
fonctionner nos actions nos solutions de
manière transversale ailier notre
proposition sur laquelle j'ai aussi
beaucoup travaillé et que je voudrais
vous faire partager cela concerne les
personnes âgées les personnes âgées
nécessiteuses eh bien vous savez
qu'elles ont droit à ce qu'on appelle
une allocation supplémentaire de
retraite et bien sachez que au décès de
ces personnes les endroits est tenu de
rembourser cette allocation c'est une
allocation c'est cette remboursement
plutôt qu'il n'avait même pas imaginer
un moment de sa vie qui dit qu'il
ignorait tout simplement et auquel il
doit faire face alors je travaillais oui
sur une proposition de loi que j'ai
nommé d'ailleurs la loi np sas pas pour
indiquer pour dire non à la transmission
à la succession de l'allocation
supplémentaire de retraite qui est
réservé aux personnes âgées qui le
nécessitent voilà alors brièvement
disons en 30 secondes qu'avez vous à
dire aux électeurs vous pouvez vous
adresser à eux eh bien chers et
lectrices chers lecteurs je vous dis que
si vous m'accordez votre confiance eh
bien je serai votre ambassadrice
indispensable auprès du pouvoir de
l'état je serai votre député qui
s'engagera durant cinq années avec
détermination
avec audace pour faire remonter nos
problématiques au sein de la délégation
territoriale
des députés et puis nos diversités pour
vous pour nous
astrid re d'ap merci merci christine
cuppitt